in this video I want to talk about the
specifics of DNA replication what are
the enzymes involved and what is the
replication fork look like so what needs
to happen in DNA replication there are
three main things that we want to keep
in mind so the first thing that we need
to do is we need to separate the two DNA
strands and we also want to keep them
apart as we're polymerizing keep them
apart then what we want to do is we want
to create or synthesize a new anti
parallel and complementary strand for
each existing strand meanwhile we want
to make sure nothing gets up gets messed
up
nothing gets up excuse me make sure
nothing gets messed up we want to make
sure that nothing is damaged or ruined
when we're doing all of this so what's
going to happen so we start off with
double-stranded DNA and then this enzyme
this little I draw it as like a green
circle here something like this comes
over and it begins to unwind the helix
this thing is called helicase so
helicase comes in and it melts or unzips
the DNA and then we get the little
replication bubble so we're going to
zoom in on this portion here this
portion is called the replication fork
okay so now if we imagine we have a
strand this top strand is running 5
prime to 3 Prime and that means this
bottom strand is running 5 artists you
find the other way so the first thing
that happens is of course this helicase
is working on this trying to go through
and and unwind the the helix some more
it's pulling these strands apart
this is helicase so while helicase is
doing that I actually haven't drawn it
here I've just drawn it as two straight
lines but keep in mind at this DNA show
I would actually be a double helix right
it would be twisted about itself so what
when helicase comes in here
pulls these strands apart what it causes
is it causes the heat the turns here of
the double helix to be more tightly
coiled so helicase creates super coils I
want to mention that it creates super
coils which are basically just really
tight coils so there's this enzyme
called a topoisomerase and what
topoisomerase does is it relieves the
tension like the super coils cause so
this here I'm going to draw is
topoisomerase this does this relieves
tension caused by super coils okay there
is a specific top why some race called
DNA gyrase that exists in prokaryotes ok
DNA gyrase is a specific to apply sama
race and the way it works is it actually
adds negative super coils to positive
super coils to undo them okay so
topoisomerase is the general term
associated with an enzyme that relieves
the tension caused by super coils and
DNA jar is a specific one that exists in
prokaryotes
okay so helicase is unwinding this helix
as soon as these these strands here are
free then there are these little
proteins that bind these strands the
single-stranded DNA so this is this here
still double-stranded DNA but these here
are single strands now these single
strands are valid as little proteins
these things are called single stranded
binding proteins
or SS VP what they do they actually have
two functions one thing is that they
protect the single-stranded DNA from
degradation okay so these these strands
once they're single-stranded they they
can be acted upon by nucleases maybe in
the environment so these single stranded
binding proteins protect the DNA strand
from being degraded another thing is it
also keeps these strands from Rhea
kneeling so if you imagine that kind of
like this it keeps the strands from
coming back together keeps the
single-stranded DNA molecules apart okay
so what's going to happen after that
then our good old friend that we've
mentioned before prime ace comes in and
lays down an RNA primer okay so now
let's think about this for a second if
this is the three prime end here that
means the news the new DNA needs to be
running from starting from here on the
five prime going down this way right and
if this is the five prime end of this
one then our the DNA here is going to be
going towards it right five hundred
three prime so we're going to add so
we're going to add a primer right here
and that's going to be the five prime
end okay so this primer here that is a
primer and that is laid down by prime
ace right which is what a special RNA
polymerase because primates can
synthesize de novo so once that is there
what the what's the purpose of that the
purpose of that is to have or to give
DNA polymerase a free three prime OAH
group to act on so once this primer is
here then DNA polymerase can go in go in
and begin to polymerize five prime to
three prime so it will start going this
way
okay so the end that blue portion that
DNA is going to be done by DNA
polymerase now if this is a eukaryote it
would just be a DNA polymerase but in a
prokaryote it would be three DNA
polymerase three in prokaryotes because
it's the main DNA polymerase as far as
extending the chain so DNA polymerase
and DNA polymerase 3 in prokaryotes this
elongate the DNA now of course it's
doing it 5 prime to 3 prime right
starting at the 5 prime end going
towards the 3 prime end now this one
gets to go down like this now we get to
bear in mind is that helicase is going
to continue unwinding these this this
strand these two strands so when it does
that that will allow this DNA polymerase
to continue to go 5 prime to 3 prime but
notice this bottom strand is going to
have a problem because this is the 5
prime end which means the 3 prime end
will end over here so we have to start 5
prime so the primer what it's going to
prime AC is going to lay down a primer
it can lay it down the the best place to
lay it down is right here right because
that's the furthest place that it can it
can add it so that's going to be the 5
prime end there and then DNA polymerase
can come in and extend it 5 prime
towards the 3 prime okay so that occurs
there so primer lays down both of these
or primates plays lays down both of
these primers here right and then DNA
polymerase extends both of those chains
okay now moments later all we'll see is
that this strand up here can continually
synthesize if we have that primer up
there it can continue to synthesize as
this thing opens up some more okay I'm
not going to draw helicase or
topoisomerase just for the sake of time
I wanna make this video
take forever but this thing can keep
going it can synthesize continuously
whereas but this bottom strand we
initially had this primer right so maybe
that was like right here somewhere and
then from there we went down and went
ahead and we don't went 5 prime to 3
prime so here at the top
oops here we went 5 prime to 3 Prime
we're still going strong 5 prime to 3
prime in this direction this one went 5
prime to 3 prime and then it's done
right but it hasn't synthesized this
portion so now another primer needs to
be added here because now that the
Strand is opened up some more another
primer can be laid down and then
extension of the DNA can occur some more
so now this top strand has a specific
name it's called the leading strand loop
saw that's really thick let me make that
thinner in a little bit this top strand
is called the leading strand because it
synthesizes continuously
this bottom strand however is called the
lagging strand because it synthesizes
discontinuously oops not dist
discontinuously
because every as it opens up more and
more we can lay down another primer then
it can elongate later on another primer
can elongate so these little portions
here are called as you may know Okazaki
fragments so this here is no kisaki
fragment this here is an Okazaki
fragment these are Okazaki fragments
these are Okazaki fragments so these
Okazaki fragments they have these little
gaps between them so those little gaps
need to be sealed so what seals them
there's an enzyme called DNA ligase
it'll go through and seal those gaps
okay so these Okazaki fragments a little
bit of information a little bit more
information about them is that they will
exist both in prokaryotes and eukaryotes
but in prokaryotes they will be about
1,000 to 2,000 nucleotides long and T
stands for nucleotides
whereas eukaryotes they'll be shorter
they'll be around 100 to 200 nucleotides
long which is kind of a little bit
counterintuitive you would think that
there would be because the the
chromosomes of eukaryotes were longer
you would think these Okazaki fragments
would be longer but that's not the case
they're actually shorter okay
so eventually this will complete and you
will have two double stranded DNA
molecules coming from 1 okay this is of
course a semiconservative replication
right these two gray strands of the
initial parent strands but eventually
what you'll get is two strands that are
with one one gray strand one blue strand
so one thing I do want to mention though
is that the enzyme DNA polymerase one in
the case of of prokaryotes right this is
assuming it's a prokaryote will go back
get rid of that primer remove the primer
and replace it with DNA in eukaryotic
it's a little bit different there's an N
there's this thing this this enzyme
called le n which it's a certain nucleus
and there's also this thing called RNAs
RNA CH which is involved in removing the
primer ok those things remove the primer
in eukaryotes and we'll talk about that
some more later ok so that's pretty much
it as far the enzymes go for DNA
replication I hope that video is helpful
one last thing I am a tutor if you live
in Southern California feel free to
contact me if you know iMovie University
i gmail.com see the description below
for more details
thank you for watching